well this is actually a major operation
a new sort of kind of operation that
started just after one o'clock this
morning with air strikes from a drone uh
at what the Israeli military would
described as a joint operations center
uh for Palestinian militants in the
Janine refugee camp about three minutes
later uh Israeli troops went in we think
there's around 2 000 Israeli troops
involved in this operation and they are
there we're told to Target
infrastructure to seize weapons and to
Target command and control centers the
IDF the Israeli military say that the
death toll amongst Palestinians is now
seven
no reports of casualties on the Israeli
side and no indication how long this
will go on for but I think we could be
looking at a couple of days and the
reason that this is different is because
Janine which is a Palestinian town in
the northern West Bank has over last few
months been
the center and in a way the staging post
if you like for a number of Terror
operations either against Israelis or
Israeli forces in the West Bank or into
Israel itself just last week for example
uh there was a video showing an
attempted uh Rockets being fired from
the West Bank into Israel they failed
but that gives you some indication of
what Israel is now trying to combat and
so Netanyahu had been under pressure by
some of his government to launch a
wide-scale military operation to sort of
bring this terrorism to an end across
the West Bank it looks though instead
he's chosen to limit it to Janine and so
I think that we could be seeing Israeli
forces operating in the city for much of
this week they won't put a time limit on
it of course but I think this will be an
operation that lasts some time